and they are taking on the young lifting
making his first major league start el
problema jesus lizardo has been dynamic
out of the bullpen for the oakland a's
and as we have mentioned looking to get
it going on the mound as a starter for
the first time in his young career
[Music]
perfectly located off speed pitch down
and away and got him high fastball at 97
miles an hour pretty impressive first
inning of work for jesus lizardo
the texas rangers who are without two
fists of their starting rotation no
corey kluber
they're gonna send lance lynn to the
mound in pursuit of his 100th victory
was in line for that w last time out
before the diamondbacks
spoiled it so it's probably nice to see
a familiar foe
and lynn dispatches simeon on strikes
payoff pitch and this one out of the
left field a bit of a run
out there and left for garcia but he's
able to track it down and the inning is
done so one two three four lens
and on three pitches frazier is gone
change up
off the plate
lizardo's gonna have to throw quickly he
does and they got him
heck of a play by jesus lizardo
throws out scott heinemann six up
six down for the young left-hander in
his first
major league star
there's a hot shot up the middle and
isaiah connor falefa
is the first base runner of the game for
either team
so it's full trying for third to throw
got it
connor falefa
saw the ball in the dirt he took off for
third murphy hustled after it and threw
a perfect strike to chapman
the scottie goes after the first pitch
drops it into center field for a lead
off single
here it comes
todd hits his ball hard out to left
field that one is down and goes to the
wall frazier cruises to second base
and he has a two out double now back
behind the plate is murphy here's the
two oh fastball rolled over to third
diving to his left picked up by chapman
gets back up throws a little bit low
staying with it as also he makes the
catch on the bounce holds on and the
inning is over that's why they both have
one gold glove so they know each other
like the back of their hand
runner left at second on to the bottom
of the fourth no score sensational play
going to his left olson digs it out and
they keep the rangers off the board
heidemann taking a strike on the outside
corner ring him up
mighty swing and a miss 96 miles an hour
and that's the strikeout
that was a challenge
a little embarrassing
the one-two
did he go he did
and there you go the fifth strike out of
the night for lance lin
and el problema is the man of the
evening
slicing and dicing his way through five
innings two hits
five punch outs on 76 pitches some great
defensive effort as well
everything you wanted to see from the
young lefty making is
debut as a starter
for the a's tonight
gallow bunting
nobody home left side of the infield and
that's a two out single
well what the heck
so here's the 2-2 pitch on the way to
frasier
left field base hit gallow
off and running
he'll have a chance to score they'll
wave him to the plate here comes the
throw
not in time and the rangers get the
first run of the game frazier kind of
hanging out between second and third
and then he'll get a little more
exercise
and
they do get him now he's gonna say olson
was
in his way
this could work and it will it's going
to drop into shallow right field for a
base hit so kemp
the ninth place hitter with a base hit
and now you roll it over to the top of
the order
kemp with a big lead he doesn't go the
one two swinging a miss a cutter off the
plate simeon chases and a big strikeout
for lancelin
his sixth strike down to the ball game
chapman
is over two he has struck out tonight
and he is fly to left
right center
that's hit well
and that baby's gone and we're tied at
one
the chap he packs his bags
all aboard
next stop
pound down
shot to right base hit bounces right in
front of gallow so tony kemp is two for
three
and that's gonna be a base hit left
field right off the end of the back
so now these are in big time business
two on nobody out in the bottom of the
ninth
so there you see the runners base is
loaded for the age as piscotti steps in
against former aide jesse chavez is
hitting the air to center should be
plenty deep heineman going back he's
still going back and that baby's gone
piscotty with a grand slam walk off and
the a's have done it again
no waiting around for steven piscotti
it's dinner time
heater down
arms down
extension pose him up biscotti
so when it's all said and done the a's
win it tonight by a final score of
5-1 the a's have won four in a row